pretty big deal right podcast you guys  probably see them on HBO all kinds of  stuff dude are you guys  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  yes  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  you can't expect you are judging by its  power  just keep on the bright orange II don't  put on a camo on my back that was good  that really made me happy you would not  think that's economics of [ __ ]  maniacs his wife a normal person is like  man I work so many years with this my  name on a marquee  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  and speed on it like they just threw a  pillow on there I got three lines on one  episode of HBO show six years ago  they're like who gives a [ __ ] max like  flavor to podcast a lot of weathers  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  oh my god that's good